sheriff's wins good morning you guys
it's chilly out there in summerlin for
those ladies and gents to be out there
doing all their
nice dancing and everything so you might
need a jacket if you're heading now look
at that gorgeous sunrise
i've been talking about daylight saving
time it is coming pretty late this year
the second sunday of march march 14th
that's because march starts on a monday
so it adds almost an extra week before
we start daylight saving time and it'll
be just
a week before spring starts so
we'll get that sunrise all the way back
to 5 53 in the morning
before we spring forward to make that
sunrise an hour later so enjoy these
early sunrises while we've got them
42 at nellis one of the coolest spots in
town and then outside the valley 38 now
in perum
30s up in mesquite 20s at caliente and
up in
tonopah and ely 41 in searchlight and
loughlin's down to 48 right now
nothing like what they're feeling though
in the deep freeze of the northern
plains in the upper midwest
all of that cold cold polar air
continues to slide southward look at
denver in the single digits and then
even dallas is down in below freezing
this morning
st louis is in the teens nashville in
the 30s
that's cold all right we've got a couple
of storms coming our way between now
and valentine's day the first one is
already pushing clouds into california
and we'll start to see a few of these
high clouds through later today and
especially tonight
and could bring us showers by tomorrow
morning about a 20
chance enjoy the sunshine while we've
got it we'll get to a high of
70 degrees wow isn't that nice so
70 degrees today clouds late today into
tonight
and then by tomorrow morning again about
a 20 percent chance
of some showers and then mostly sunny
through the day the system will move
through pretty quickly
we'll look for upper 60s tomorrow then
big winds come with that second system
that's stronger and colder and it looks
like it will bring us
possible late day showers saturday into
saturday night
remember how we were talking about maybe
some rain on valentine's day
it looks like this system will be gone
and we'll be looking for sunny skies on
valentine's day
but breezy north winds on sunday the
biggest win
saturday breezes on sunday a little bit
cooler president's day mostly sunny
nice and a lot of 60s next week with
sunshine